مجتمع اليمني في مجمله مجتمع محافظ الا ان
قرارات الحوثيين الاخيره تنظر بمزيد من
التشدد تجاه حقوق النساء ولا سيام قرار
منعهم من السفر من دون محرم
من قبل الحوثيين في مطار صنعاء قلت بدل ما
اسافر من مطار صنعاء سافر من مطار عدن
وانا بطريقي لعدم تم نعيم مره ثانيه من
قبل الحوثيين تعيشوا عبير في تعز التي
يحاصرها من السفر ضيع عليها فرصه التحاق
بمنحه دراسيه في القاهره
مسافر عن شان اا ابني مستقبلي وادرس كذا
يعني هذا الشيء بسيط
ومقدرتش كما اقدم الحوثيون على اغلاق بركي
سباحه وصاله الرياضيه للنساء في صنعاء
والوضع اسوا في المناطق النائيه وفي صعده
معسل الجماعه حيث منعت النساء من التنقل
بعد السادسه مساء بمفردهم وكلفت شرطه باسم
الزينبيات لتاكد من احترام النساء للضوابط
المفروضه نشطاء حقوقيون يصفون ما يجري في
مناطق حكم الحوثيين بطلبنه المجتمع اليمني
في اشاره الى حركه طالبان
فقط
عبر الكتابه وفضح هذه الاساليب واستنكارها
او عبر التواصل مع المجتمع الدولي في حاله
انه يستطيع الضغط على هذه المليشيات
والمجتمع اليمني قادر ايضا على الضغط فقد
نجح سكان صنعاء في ثني الحوثيين عن قرار
منع حفلات التخرج المختلطه او منع
الموسيقى